My name is Lars Moravy, I'm the vice
president of vehicle engineering at
Tesla Motors a lot of people love Crossovers
and they love crossovers for the right reasons
there's a lot of storage there's a lot of
utility and I think what we wanted to try
to do when we made the Model Y was sort
of take that notion and just blow it up
Our cars have always had great range and great
dynamic in the mobile why we actually added what
we call off-road mode which is a little bit of
that break torque vectoring to like on steroids
maybe you're doing a little bit of river rocking
and one wheel gets off the ground we clamp that
down and the other three put torque forward so
you still keep moving and that's something gives
the model y a capability that you might not
otherwise get in pretty sporty crossover SUV
but at Tesla we always started a first principles
approach you don't get to say well we've done that
for 50 years so that's the way we're going to do
it for the next 50. you have to prove everything
you're doing from the ground up with you know
first principles of physics and mechanics and
and really that's our boundary is like what does
physics say is the envelope and that that's as
far as we'll take things there's been a lot of
talk about the rear casting and how cool it is
and what it does but one of the problems when
you make big pieces of aluminum is that they
warp when you heat treat them but with model
y we actually invented our own alloy that is
able to achieve super high levels of strength
and durability so that saves money costs energy
because we don't have to heat treat it with
these giant ovens but more importantly keeps
the part straight and that means we don't have
to machine the whole thing from an engineering
geek out standpoint that's like one of the coolest
parts of the thing is like yeah you can look at it
and say okay they replace the 100 Parts with one
or two but really that the alloy and the material
developed on that was super special because we
wouldn't have been able to do that without it
at Tesla we've always tried to constantly
improve our products then to integrate all
the functionality that you have in a
typical crossover is something that's
super important so the cargo space in the
rear the additional cargo space in the front
fold flat seats that give you this wide open area
if you need to do it the towing that we have on
the back end all of that combined and then saying
you know what it's still going to be a Tesla when
you drive it people that like to be dynamic
they're going to love it people that want to
sit up high and see the road they're going to love
it people that have a family and need the storage
space they're going to love it every car we build
every new product we make I want to take it a step
further I want to make people's understanding of
what an EV can be and what a product is make it
a part of your life a part of your experience
ultimately it results in a product people love
and that's when you know you've hit the right
point of vehicle engineering [Music] foreign